a cart of mass m moving rightward at
speed 2v
hits a slower moving cart of mass m
moving rightward at speed v
when the carts collide they hook
together there's friction between the
track and carts and between the moving
parts of the carts
which of the following best represents
the momentum of the left side cart as a
function of time before and after the
collision so before we even look at the
choices let's see if we can sketch it
out ourselves so pause this video and
see if you can make a sketch of what the
momentum of the left side cart would
look like as a function of time and
actually try to do it for the right side
card while you're at it
all right now let's do this together so
just to make sure we understand what's
going on this cart is moving to they
have the same mass this left card is
moving to the right with the velocity of
2v the cart on the right has the same
mass and it's moving to the right with
half the velocity and since momentum is
mass times velocity this will also have
half the momentum so one way to think
about it is if on our vertical axis let
me draw a straighter line
if on our vertical axis
we have momentum
momentum
and on our horizontal axis we have time
so this is
time
right over there
so this left cart will start with some
momentum but since there's friction in
the system especially in the mechanics
of this cart you're going to see it slow
down the force of friction is going
against the direction of motion so it's
going to decelerate it and then it's
going to hit the other slower moving
cart
and that other slo and one way to think
about it is some of that momentum will
get transferred to the slower moving
cart because then they're going to be
moving together at the same velocity and
so you could imagine and then at that
slower velocity it will continue to
decelerate because of the friction and
so the graph of momentum over time of
the left cart might look something like
that
now just for kicks if you want to think
about what about the right cart well the
right cart has the same mass but half
the velocity so it's going to have half
the initial momentum and so it would
also degrade it would look something
like this
but then right at the collision
the right cart would gain momentum and
then they should go together like that
so these are the lines for each
individual one and if you wanted a
combined system
well then you would add these momentums
and you would have something that just
would be a line that degrades but anyway
they asked us about the left cart and so
we said hey something
something that looks like this
should work out so let's look at the
choices
so
this first choice
has two problems with it
first it shows a world in which you have
no friction it's just the momentum stays
constant and so that means it's velocity
to the right is staying constant and
then when it's trying to show the
collision it makes the momentum negative
and this would imply that all of a
sudden that cart would be moving to the
left where the convention that we
typically use is right is positive and
left is negative and so we can rule this
one out
this second one looks a little bit
better but once again it's assuming a
world without friction where the
velocity stays constant and so the
momentum stays constant until you have
the collision and then you still have it
after the collision the momentum stays
constant so we can rule that out if they
said it was frictionless this is what we
would have picked
choice d
it's looking good in the beginning but
then it shows that the momentum goes to
zero implying that the left cart just
comes to a standstill and once again we
would not expect that and so we would
rule that out and so this is very close
to what we drew choice b